CHRIS LEE ARE THE REFEREES AND
VON RODY AND TIME
PLAYING WITH PAUL STASTNY.
LOOK AT THE FORECHECK FROM
TRIED TO GET IT FOR PIERRE-LUC
EICHEL PLAYS IT BACK FOR SHEA
THEODORE.
THEODORE BAC GOOD POINT BLANK
EHLERS TRYING TO SPIN OFF A
CHECK.T IT.
PI RIGHT POINT
WHEELER TRIED TO GO CROSS-ICE,
REBOUND, SCORE!
[Horn sounds]ISTIC.
THIS IS A PASS THAT'S MEANT TO
GO THROUGH THAT SEAM.
AND I THINK IT HITS PIERRE-LUC
DUBOIS' SKATE.INK WIDE.
SOME ROOM FOR KYLE CONNOR.
IN FOR SVECHNIKOV, SCORES!
[Horn s LOOK AT THAT.
MIDDLE DRIVE NOT.
YOU LOOK AT THE MIDDLE OF THE
ICE.
THE HEEL
THE BACK LEFT HEEL OF DUBOIS
LOOKS LIKE IT'S
COMES RIGHT BACK FOR EICHEL.
COGHLAN PLAYS IT AROUND THE
BOARDS AND OUT TO CENTRE.
INTERCEPTED BY KYLE CONNOR.
EHLERS, GETS DOUBLE-TEAMED.
SLIDES IT ON TO MORRISSEY.
DOWN LOW.O GUYS ON HIM BUT HE AH
CONNOR.
ADAM BROOKS CHASES ITNIGHTS TUR
QUICKLY WITH EICHEL.
EICHEL WILL DROP IT BACK.
COGHLAN T
>> Kevin: RIGHT OFF THE CHEST.
PIECE OF THAT?
>> Kevin: WELL THAT IS THE PLAY
MORRISSEY.
MORRI GOALS ON THE YEAR FOR ADA
OTTAWA HERE THURSDAY.
COLUMBUS WITH PATRIK LAINE HERE
ON FRIDAY. BEEN
EXCELLENT.
STASTNY CALMING PRESENCE AS HE .
LOOK AT THE WAY HE SCRAMBLES
THROUGH TRAFFIC.
GIVES HIS STICK AND NICE JOB
JUST KEEPINGT.
ANOTHER BLOCK FOR HIM.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE A COUPLE OF
HANDFULS OF BLOCKED SHOTS.8-3-1